[Music]
Ben Affleck revealed on Facebook Tuesday
he's completed a stint in rehab but his
history with addiction goes back much
further your dad was an alcoholic my
father was a call a real alcoholic he
you know he drank all day drank every
day and to his credit he he got sober
ultimately and he's been sober for
several decades which i think is pretty
impressive in july 2001 then 29 year old
Ben went to rehab in Malibu he spoke
about his experience in 2012 to The
Hollywood Reporter explaining quote I
went to rehab for being 29 in partying
too much and not having a lot of
boundaries and to clear my head and try
to get some idea of who I wanted to be
how do you make all that work mean you
guys got a lot going on
Fedora busts in 2004 been married his
daredevil co-star Jennifer Garner a
source tells et it was Jen who put a
stop to Ben's hard partying ways
according to the source
Jen's positive influence lasted for a
long time until the pair split in June
2015
Ben thanked Jen in his Facebook post
Tuesday calling out his co-parent for
supporting him and caring for their kids
during his time in treatment this is
really rewarding a separate source
explained to et Ben did this for himself
but noted family always comes first
I feel great this is really exciting
[Music]
you